just because waiting back makes up lies
about the multiverse doesn't mean it
isn't real dr. strange and the mobile
person madness say hi in the director
scott derrickson I mean what excites me
about dr. strange is what made him great
in the comics that he doesn't fight
villains from this earth or even from
this universe but from the multiverse or
other dimensions so you get into all
kinds of psychedelic weirdness which
this movie is going to but when I came
and talked to Kevin about doing a sequel
I said I don't want to do just another
sequel to do a sequel if I'm gonna do it
it has to go into the territory that
drew me into the Doctor Strange comics
in the first place which is how they
dipped into the Gothic and the horror
and the horrific and we're gonna make
the first scary MCU film so what's next
for him
just easy softball questions I think
yeah just some you know home economics
and cooking ware and a kind of crazy
line in horror I'm really excited to be
at the dawn of this project and I think
it's vital to maintain the integrity of
humor and stuff that we had in the first
film but with this twist of horror which
I think will really have people correct
is that twist of horror gonna change any
way that you approach him as a character
at all or um he'll be facing unexpected
things I think he'll be in a position
rather like the audience of not knowing
what's coming at it there was a long
Authority to his character I thought in
the Avengers iterations and even in Thor
as well so we're going back to kind of
trying to destroy him a bit I think
early days but when you have a strong
sorcerer it also helps when you have a
strong witch and the Scarlet Witch is
appearing in this movie alongside
so Elizabeth thanks for joining us back
on stage that being said is there
anything that you can tell us about how
your Disney Plus show will play into
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness I don't know if I could answer
the how but I think it's I'm really
excited to be able to link one story on
one medium and bring it into the futures
we haven't done that yet and I think
that's super unique time for you and I
think that might be the future but I
don't know anything I really like the
character of Nightmare and the concept
that the nightmare nightmare realm is a
dimension I always thought that was one
of the that's early that's like in the
first strange tale I think that's an
introductory EPs episode of Doctor
Strange and I always loved that well we
decided not to do that just because
that's a bit of a complex idea to try to
introduce everything that we do
introduced and introduced the idea of
nightmares themselves as being another
dimension I hope somewhere down the line
we get to explore that except I think
that's a super cool concept everybody is
Charlie we had to break down that big
teaser they dropped at Comic Con for
Doctor Strange to the multiverse of
madness the big Scarlet Witch crossover
there are a lot of details that they
were filled about the movie we know who
the villain is and we know what they're
gonna be doing with the Scarlet Witch
characters because of all this craziness
we're doing the Avengers endgame blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a Marvel phase
for a comment on the video I'll name a
new winner at the end of this
interestingly enough some of what's
going on during Doctor Strange 2 also
invokes or calls back to some of the
stuff that happened during spider-man
far from home so I'll explain when we
get to that part but breaking this down
top 7 style number 7 Kevin Feige
confirms as we all suspected that the
multiverse is real despite all of the
lies that Mysterio was spitting out
during spider-man far from home you're
saying there's a multiverse the reason
why spider-man has no idea what's going
on with the multiverse and is learning
about it for the first time here is
because they established it during the
original Doctor Strange movie and even
though spider-man was alive during the
events of that movie as all the other
Avengers were they had nothing to do
with that movie so only Doctor Strange
got that tutorial in the multiverse but
I think you can assume that other really
smart people like Tony Stark if he can
crack time-travel he there knows about
or has theories about the multiverse
already so if you had a conversation
with Ironman about the multiverse he
wouldn't be as blown away by it as
spider-man would be I'm sorry you're
saying there's a multiverse because I
thought that was just theoretical I mean
that completely changes how we
understand the initial singularity
deceasing sorry but hopefully that
explains what was going on with that
line in spider-man far from home that
was one of the biggest questions I got
after that movie came out wait a minute
does that mean that the multiverse is
fake no no the multiverse is real
Mysterio was only lying about being from
another earth six they confirmed that
the movies gonna be Marvel's first legit
horror film and the main villain is
going to be nightmare as the director
says during his interview I just feel
like he's a really interesting villain
that he's from a dimension that is the
nightmare dimension if you haven't read
a lot of the Doctor Strange comics
nightmare is one of the fear Lords from
the halls of fear that's where their
bases the halls of fear is also what
they call the dimension that he comes
from so he's part of a group of a bunch
of really powerful beings some of them
being legit demons some of them being
gods from other dimensions themselves so
the fear Lords are despair the dweller
in the darkness the lurking unknown
nightmare in Knox the way it seems like
the movie is going to use nightmare is
that he's from a dream dimension that
overlays our own which explains a little
about how he can penetrate the dreams of
people in our own dimension when he
exists in another one so imagine in the
wake of the snap you have all this
cosmic energy giving up weakening the
barrier between dimensions I know it
still sounds like Mysterio's fake
explainer but as Kevin Feige says he
wasn't lying about every single thing so
weakening the barrier allows nightmare
to control more people's minds within
our dimension that's why Doctor Strange
gets involved because his primary role
as sorcerer supreme is to protect our
earth from threats from other dimensions
what is your job exactly besides making
balloon animals
protecting your reality douche bag like
the director says that's one of the
reasons why he likes the Doctor Strange
characters because most of his villains
are from other dimensions 5 they confirm
Scarlet Witch is going to crossover and
the plot of her one division TV show
will tie in with a plot of Doctor
Strange too the reason for this actually
makes more sense when you remember what
one of her core abilities is
manipulating the minds of other people
so you
a character like nightmare who's just
crazy powerful with godlike abilities to
do something like that but dr. strange
hasn't demonstrated any kind of psychic
abilities so far so if he was going to
fight someone with that he would need
help from someone like Scarlet Witch who
does have psychic abilities and
experience manipulating other people's
minds the plot of the Wanda Vision TV
show is a little bit weirder Kevin Feige
kind of teased that it's the weirdest
thing that they've ever tried but the
way crosses over with dr. strange - has
more to do with her just developing her
abilities like she herself teased you
will learn why she's called
scarlet witch she's talking about
full-blown Scarlet Witch Chaos magic
reality warping so didn't you think it
was weird that even though she's powered
by the mine stone or the mind stone
unlocked her abilities her physical
powers when she's using them look more
like the red of the reality stone so one
division will be more theater of the
mind Legion style like they're going to
be doing a little bit of Tom King's
vision run where vision was trying to
lead a normal suburban life with the
family and it kind of winds up going off
the rails but think about Scarlet Witch
because it's called Wanda vision as if
you're watching the series through her
perspective so a lot of it really does
sound like Marvel doing a version of the
Legion TV show he conjures up all these
visions he shows people things he
changes people in really fundamental
ways but it's all happening in your mind
which explains how they can have the
vision on the TV show without bringing
him back to life in present-day after
the end of Avengers endgame when they
brought him on stage Paul Bettany was
like I have no idea how I'm in this
series I have no idea how they brought
me back I don't know what's going on
because it's probably going to be
theater of the mind vision not real life
vision coming back there was an
interview before Avengers end game came
out during the press junket where she
also called it very 1950s that doesn't
literally mean that the series is taking
place in 1950 in they're going back in
time it just means more of this theater
of the mind space that she creates has a
very 1950s vibe to it
like you're stepping into her fantasy
and her fantasy looks like it's taking
place during the 1950's things will
probably go off the rails a little bit
but that will enter the stage for
nightmare as a character to penetrate
her dreams and her to get involved with
Doctor Strange for if you were listening
really careful to what Kevin Feige was
saying he
quietly confirmed another big fan theory
that the clea character will probably
appear during the movie longtime love
interest of dr. strange from another
dimension when he was introducing
Scarlet Witch on stage he says when you
have a strong sorcerer it helps if you
have a strong witch in the scarlet
witch's appearing in this movie
alongside her her as in female sorcerer
which is the clea character 3 this is
another Spider Man far from home moment
because all the movies are taking place
in a relatively short time span being
trapped in the Nightmare Realm is
probably why Doctor Strange was
unavailable to help spider-man during
spider-man far from home he would have
shut that Mysterio elementals business
down immediately like he wouldn't even
have to leave the sanctum in New York
City to tell Nick Fury and Maria hill
that the elementals are not real yeah
that's just a bunch of drones with Stark
Industries itched on the side you're
gonna want to give a call to Pepper
Potts to ask her about that too remember
how there was a rumor about Quicksilver
appearing in Avengers endgame regardless
of what that deleted scene would have
wound up being logically the easiest way
for him to come back for a cameo in a
movie is through the multiverse and
through scarlet witch's nightmares when
they're fighting the nightmare character
in one the reason why this movie the
Doctor Strange sequel is one of the most
important Marvel movies in Marvel phase
4 next to the Eternals in terms of
setting up the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as you probably
suspected is because of what it does
with the multiverse setting the stage
for their next major major Thanos
Infinity Gauntlet level event aka
Avengers secret Wars after all those
Marvel panels this weekend Kevin Feige
did an interview confirming that they're
doing the same thing with the newer
movies teasing the next big big thing
that they're working up to the exact
same way they tease fan OHS at the end
of the first Avengers movie with the
Infinity Gauntlet in the Infinity stones
so in the next couple of movies you will
see hints in the background of what it
is they're building up to in the next
couple of phases next to the Eternals
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness is just the beginning of that
setting the stage for all these
alternate universes to collide many
years down the road and even the Russos
were being funny this past weekend with
the writers of infinity war and endgame
joking
that in order to do the secret war story
justice you would have to
as a six film series all by itself
and that's just crazy there's no way
Marvel is gonna break an Avengers movie
into six different Avengers movies but
maybe more than one film for sure like
they broke Avengers infinity war in
Avengers endgame into two separate films
as for introducing the Fantastic Four
and the x-men characters I don't think
that they'll purely be a multiverse
alternate earth story I think when we
see them for the first time they'll all
come from our dimension and they'll have
a way of explaining how they've been
here we just haven't known about them
until now I'm working on more Avengers
endgame deleted scenes and bonus
features that have been dropping there's
a new shang-chi Iron Man Mandarin video
that I'm working on and spider-man far
from home deleted scenes so if you have
any big requests for Marvel videos just
leave them in the comments below and
I'll say congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last big video smudgy
ghosts 3:30 please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details
everybody click here for my Avengers and
game Iron Man alternate ending deleted
scene and click here for my breakdown of
the black widow Comic Con trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]